russia that it produces roughly about
two-thirds of the world's fertilizer has
decided to temporarily suspend exports
joining me now is ben neal who owns a
farm in oklahoma
ben um good to see you tonight now we're
coming up of course on the spring
planning season
how could this affect you and then
consumers down the line going forward
hi laura thanks for having me uh we're
getting hit on every front on every
expense possible from fertilizer to fuel
to labor insurance uh everything in
between our packing supplies so we
operate a small farm in oklahoma a
hundred percent of our sales are farm to
home delivery and um so we are driving
across the state and you know the fuel
costs are really painful for us
well when you think about what it costs
now just for you know a dozen eggs or a
pound of ground beef versus a year ago
and then you add in the cost of fuel on
top of that what it costs to
grow crops with these increased prices
of fertilizer and the shortage of
fertilizer we might have
what kind of increase in in your monthly
bills
are you looking at here
well i would say our increases are
roughly 25 to 30 percent and i think
that that will soon be reflected at the
grocery stores and you know on top of
what we're already seeing um these these
fertilizer uh price increases haven't
really affected the grocery store prices
yet but they will start coming uh this
summer
well i i just don't think anyone's even
thinking about that i mean i haven't
heard
one politician then
address that one issue without
fertilizer
we don't have crops
or am i missing something
everybody eats and it affects everybody
and it it is going to hit everybody's
household and we need to figure out what
we're doing with american energy and we
need to start producing more at home
bringing back to that point of american
made
your your crops are american-made
doesn't this tell us once and for all
that it's time to bring it all home as
much of key industries as we can bring
back to the united states
yeah i mean i i find myself asking a
question probably like most americans
why are we buying oil from countries
that hate us when we can produce all of
our own oil at home and solve this
problem oh by the way just for fun ben
cause i know you need to be entertained
tonight
cnn thinks the best way to kind of
bamboozle the public on all these
increasing prices
is by telling stories watch for
people who are working for people who
are in rural america this is really
going to be very very painful not only
is it a gas price issue it's going to be
milk it's going to be rent it's going to
be all of these prices are going up we
have to let the american people really
understand it is an explanation but if
you do it well and you're a great
storyteller i think that they will
understand why we're in the situation
i mean jake tapper was actually showing
a lot of concern for the consumers but
kind of the panel was engaging in this
well we just need to tell stories about
then people will feel good about
spending 30 more of the on their food
budget do you buy that
yeah stories are great but they don't
pay the bills and they don't they don't
pay my payroll for my employees um and
and fuel costs and things like that and
so we're tired of the stories it it's
time to see some action
ben it's so good to hear from you
tonight someone is actually producing
something thank you